I'm you and Ashley I'm associate
professor of cardiovascular medicine and
genetics and by courtesy the department
of pathology at Stanford University and
the Medical Center I'm also a director
of the clinical genomic service at
Stanford and of the Center for inherited
cardiovascular disease I am an MD ph.d
but coming from Scotland initially none
of my degrees are called MD or PhD I
have a medical degree from the
University of Glasgow in Scotland have a
PhD from the University of Oxford in
England and I completed my medical
training in cardiology at Stanford
University here in California my lab is
is principally focused on thinking about
the genetic basis of cardiac disease but
also we're very focused on developing
computational algorithms for the
interpretation of the human genome in
particular to be applied broadly to
medicine so we have both computational
components in the lab as well as a wet
lab so we have people who are growing
heart cells and looking at hearts in the
dish thinking about stem cell technology
and ultimately we want to connect the
genetic diagnosis of disease with the
potential development of new therapy I
think will increasingly see genome
sequencing be brought to the bedside of
more and more patients and being
relevant for more and more patients I
think in particular we'll start to see
cancer come through where we're
sequencing cancers and thinking about
being more precise about the therapy we
can give to cancer patients but then
also I think we'll go much broader than
cancer and think about using
pharmacogenomics the influence of the
genome on prescribing decisions by
doctors to really start to personalize
medicine for everyone and so I think
that the genomic technology will really
start to impact every corner of medicine
over the next five or ten years
you